[Musique]
calibre 5 56 4 kilos 3 avec les
munitions
le FAMAS et le fusil d'assaut
emblématique de l'armée française
et l'équipe les troupes depuis 1983
les cibles sont à 25 mètres elle simule
un ennemi à 100 mètres et 100 mètres ça
fait loin
il voulait sortir des plateaux prendre
l'air tâter le terrain
ils ne vont pas être déçus
Carole Rousseau et Benjamin Castaldi
partent à la rencontre d'hommes et de
femmes ordinaires aux métiers
extraordinaire
[Musique]
la guerre il faut aussi savoir la faire
en montagne par tous les temps deux
jours comme de nuit
ces hommes s'entraînent au combat dans
les sommets donner report de tir à
droite ce sont les chasseurs alpins une
troupe d'élite de l'armée française je
vais passer une semaine avec eux et je
vais devoir m'accrocher et là je suis à
la limite de ce que je peux faire ils
vont m'apprendre à me battre sur des
skis à reprendre un col à l'ennemi
[Musique]
à survivre sous une avalanche
je vais aller au bout de mes forces
qu'est-ce que c'est dur et je veux même
apprendre à fabriquer mon propre igloop
pour dormir au pied du Mont Blanc c'est
bon chez moi
à l'école militaire de haute montagne
ça vous gagne
lundi matin retour de permis les élèves
sont en rang c'est 8 heures
c'est un stage auquel j'attache une
importance particulière voilà vous êtes
l'avenir de la brigade donc on en est
bien conscient et on va vous on va vous
peaufiner vous allez ramasser repos
on va ramasser
ils ont de 18 à 24 ans vin d'entre eux
se sont engagés il y a plusieurs années
les deux autres sont de jeunes recrues
de moins de 6 mois
dans un an chacun commandera un groupe
de 9 soldats ces militaire sont des
spécialistes du combat en conditions
extrêmes ils ont fait l'Afghanistan le
Tchad et en ce moment ils sont en
première ligne dans le Sahel il va
falloir être à la hauteur et à 25 kg de
matos comment te dire que là je suis pas
bien
et j'aime pas les skis aux pieds
ça commence comme une sortie entre potes
il fait beau on rigole on s'entasse dans
les œufs l'occasion de faire
connaissance avec ces jeunes qui ont
fait le choix des armes et de la
montagne
vous êtes déjà dans l'armée depuis un
moment
quatre ans
[Rires]
j'avais jamais mis les pieds sur les
skis donc c'était une découverte totale
je descends
c'est au pied du Mont Blanc que depuis
1932 officiers et sous-officier de
l’armée de terre se forment au combat en
montagne oh punaise première descente et
déjà première difficulté
le plus c'est hyper dur avec le sac à
dos
[Musique]
il faut
la technique reste allumée
je comprends tout de suite que ça ne
sera pas des vacances
ici les skis de savent pas seulement à
descendre les pistes ils servent aussi à
grimper au sommet et pour cela il y a
les pots de phoques on les place sous
les spatules comme ça les skis
s'accroche à la neige le skieur peut
progresser sans risque de glisser en
arrière ah oui j'ai vu
pendant que le premier groupe débute
l'ascension à pied moi je suis prise en
main par le doyen des formateurs Eric 37
ans de service et après la difficulté
maintenant ça va être de transposer mon
poids parce que là je suis sur le ski
aval le transposer le ski le poids sur
les skis qui est en haut il m'explique
comment tourner dans la pente mon pied
sur le site pour m'équilibrer effacer et
tourner bon là c'est fait beaucoup de
choses que je viens de dire mais on va
ce n'est pas simple et encore je suis
sur le plat
à la conversion c'est quand même pas
simple mais une fois qu'on l'a compris
après on est quand même bien à l'aise
dans les dans les conversions on va
monter tranquillement
[Musique]
c'est parti pour ma première ascension
en ski de randonnée on est à 2000 mètres
j'ai fait à peine 50 mètres je suis déjà
épuisé trop chargé et trop couvert je
meurs de chaud là tu es en train de me
piquer une suer parce que tu es sur la
pointe des pieds quand je mets mon ski
sur laquelle je vais chercher mes appuis
je pose bien le salon et en appuyant
dessus ça tient pourquoi se pencher en
avant
je galère dans mes conversions le sac me
déséquilibre les jambes me brûle
mais au moins avec mes potes je me
retrouve pas tout en bas
[Musique]
au bout de 100 mètres les plus lents les
plus chargés de la troupe double
on retrouve seul avec mon Saint-Bernard
mon chemin de croix ne fait que
commencer c'est pas les filles qui
commande le bonhomme c'est le bonhomme
qui commence
j'ai pas un problème de physique j'ai un
problème de technique qui te ruines en
fait ton physique complètement c'est ça
exactement
comme j'ai aucune technique
chaque geste que je fais et pas
économiseur de nid d'oxygène ni de
calories ni de rien donc effectivement
là où je devrais dépenser 10 en position
dépenser déjà 200 donc forcément ça
ça
fatigue plus vite
je viens de gravir en ski l'équivalent
la Tour Eiffel 300 mètres
et c'est avec beaucoup de retard que je
rattrape la troupe
à la tête de ma section un vétéran
Jérôme a fait la Bosnie et l'Afghanistan
aujourd'hui il enseigne le combat de
montagne
bon moi honnêtement j'aurais bien fait
une pause mais notre capitaine veut
monter encore plus haut
faire attention à ce qui se passe il y a
ce qu'on a sous le ski pour éviter
d'avoir une avalanche pour éviter
d'aller au mauvais endroit mais en même
temps on peut surveiller
sans éléments donc a priori si on est au
milieu c'est ce qu'on dit rien d'accord
voilà donc là maintenant comme on sait
qu'on est proche du col la nuit ce
serait dévoilé vous laisserez pas venir
aussi près soit tirer voilà maintenant
le danger peut venir de plutôt des
lignes de tête au dessus à l'horizon
voilà donc eux s'attachent à surveiller
signe de quête si quelqu'un se dévoile
là-bas à nous d'accélérer pour aller se
mettre à rue des rochers allez il y a
pas beaucoup d'abris il faut aller vite
là-bas
on file tout droit sur le col de la
glaire la leçon du jour commençant parer
et tenir un col
c'est vous qui devez définir par rouler
l'ennemi peut nous surprendre et vous
dominer c'est à vous de faire les
patrouilles dans ces points là mais tu
vas peut-être avoir un ou deux mecs qui
vont faire des patrouilles sur les
points hauts et tu en as qui vont se
reposer aussi donc faut pas penser que
tu vas occuper en permanence tous les
points
ça c'est pas possible imagine il fait le
temps qu'il a fait en début de semaine
ah oui toi tout de suite est-ce que tu
fais des patrouilles par ce temps-là
de la journée au bout d'un moment ça
devient dur de tenir non
à votre avis on vous laisserait combien
de temps un groupe ici
24 heures ça c'est quand on a les moyens
ça fait 24 heures si on a moyen de faire
des rotations mais plus tu fais monter
les gens tous les jours
plus tu les occupes pour rien monter sur
un col c'est une occupation qui sert à
rien c'est pas une patrouille parce que
dire
est-ce que nous on va subir l'ennemi va
subir aussi
imagine bien que vos trois jours quand
tu repars
tout de suite beaucoup moins en forme
pas facile
où sont les têtes d'opération militaires
Steve montagne aujourd'hui dans le monde
du terrain montagneux il y a pas besoin
d'avoir cette notion de haute altitude
pour avoir de la montagne la montagne ça
peut être un massif montagneux de
moyenne altitude et vous en été bien sûr
ça présente quand même des des problèmes
de dénivelé des problèmes de logistique
tout ce qu'on voit cette semaine on le
rencontre dès le moment il y a de la
pente on rencontre en fait eux ce qu'ils
vont rencontrer comme projet
et pouvoir s'emparer de la même d'un
petit
ça leur permet de dominer cette ennemi
éventuellement le surprendre
les préparer à remplir les missions au
mieux en invitons qui que ce soit
évidemment
cours magistral à 2500 mètres d'altitude
on en prend plein les yeux mais croyez
moi ça fatigue direction la vallée ce
soir nous dormons à la caserne
deuxième journée les armes automatiques
sont de sortie
les élèves se mettent un peu plus en
conditions de combat
[Musique]
pour ménager leur force les militaires
se font tracter au plus près de leur
objectif
c'est ce qu'on appelle du skijoring
[Musique]
moi c'était une motoneige que je me
retrouvais attachée
une sorte de ski nautique sur neige
encore une première
si il y en a un qui tombe vous décalez
de suite que les autres les embarquent
pas le temps que moi je m'arrête
[Musique]
bah c'est un peu comme un remontant en
fait
voilà ça a l'air d'accélérer un peu
c'est plus rapide qu'un monde en fait
ah oui c'est beaucoup plus rapide
il y a toujours un petit un petit muscle
qui travaille là c'est les bras
toujours ça
donc pour vous la mission c'est éclairé
en fait la progression de la section
d'accord et les formats sont devant
d'accord donc voilà en mode combat une
grande partie de la section est
expérimentée elle a déjà effectué
l'émission à l'étranger
certains ont fait l'Afghanistan le Tchad
d'autres le Sahel ou la République
centrafricaine
à droite ça veut dire que mes amis sont
en train de rentrer dans mon secteur
donc du coup mon secteur de tir va se
décaler à droite histoire de pas faire
de tirs
à ma mission c'est de surveiller et
d'appuyer par le mouvement ou par le feu
mes collègues sont en train de déborder
l'objectif par la gauche donc voilà donc
c'est pour ça que qu'à chaque phase de
mouvement il y a un appui qui est en
place on dit dans l'armée pas un pas
sans appui
donc faut d'abord se considérer comme
combattant et après comme on tient mais
d'abord combattant c'est
c'est la base
c'est la base c'est ce qu'il y a de plus
plaisant enfin pour moi c'est ce qui
apporte le plus adrénaline en opération
extérieure c'est le top
il y a donc des soldats confirmés et
ceux qui tâtonnent un peu il y a six
mois certains étaient encore des civils
j'ai l'impression qu'il cherche leur
marque et aussi leurs mots voilà du coup
vu qu'on est en hauteur c'est vraiment
pas mal par rapport à l'ennemi à être au
dessus c'est vraiment magnifique on voit
je préfère être au dessus en dessous
c'est sûr
après moi j'ai connu que les séances de
tir donc
après je pourrai pas dire mais je pense
que la réaction sera différente
je pense que c'est pas la même déjà
pensé ou tu préfères pas y penser si si
j'y pense mais après j'espère juste que
j'aurai la bonne réaction je pense que
c'est pour ça qu'on a des bons
entraînements c'est pour
ne pas paniquer quand on sera sur les
feux sous les feux
[Musique]
en France l'armée terre dispose de
100.000 hommes seuls 7000 sont des
chasseurs alpins une troupe d'élite où
l'on doit être aussi bon skieur que
tireur les skis c'est tout bon
un chargeur
un chargeur et 25 munitions nous sommes
sur un terrain militaire l'exercice se
fait à balleresse il y a pas une
technique non
quelque chose de dur on redressant un
peu voilà
on est bon sur les munitions
vous allez tirer coucher avec appui
musette ce qui a quand même de plus
stable attention quand vous mettez le
genou à terre à pas planter le canon et
faire une jolie carotte
le résultat serait assez explosif
OK
en me charger pose les bâtons
l'arme autour du cou
voilà vous avez repéré vos objectifs
disposition de combat
toujours
dans une direction non dangereuse
objectif
[Musique]
3 avec les munitions
le FAMAS et le fusil d'assaut
emblématique de l'armée française
et l'équipe les troupes depuis 1983
les cibles sont à 25 mètres elle simule
un ennemi à 100 mètres et 100 mètres ça
fait loin
ça fait
la rafale mais ça c'est plus c'est plus
d'actualité le tirant rafale non c'est
trop consommateur de munitions et c'est
imprécis dans les films quoi voilà
c'est bon
allez au résultat
c'est quoi la distance en général de
combat avec ce type les combats modernes
sont plutôt et maintenant des combats
rapprochés et des combats de rencontre
après avec le FAMAS on tire 300 mètres
un bon tireur petit 400 mètres un bon
tireur petit à 400 mètres au-delà c'est
plus l'affaire du tireur de précision
équipée d'un autre type d'armement donc
pourquoi on vit de la pointe du carré
orange ben parce que ça correspond à la
zone où il y a les organes les organes
nobles là on va on va blesser
dans le groupe d'avoir un blessé que
qu'on voudra sauver d'accord
deuxième tir
à me charger
disposition de combat
nouvelle position accroupie
donc il faut écarter
les skis voilà
à l'intérieur
bon laisse tomber
les tirs se succèdent ils doivent
devenir instinctifs
[Musique]
l'objectif mettre hors de combat
l'adversaire dès la première balle
[Musique]
ça ressemble à du tir sportif
j'en oublierai presque que ce sont des
armes de guerre et que dans quelques
mois ces hommes partiront au feu
l'armée française c'est dix dernières
années a perdu près de 200 hommes au
combat
et voilà c'est pas si mal
c'est pas si
il est mort
[Musique]
ça c'est bon chez moi pour la
[Applaudissements]
dès que tu peux tu essayes de lui parler
pour voir s'il est conscients c'est pas
abandonné comme ça
impossible
mon aventure avec les troubles de
montagne continue je vais enfin
connaître les joies de l'alpinisme
et gravir là-bas au loin mon premier pic
pas loin des 3000 mètres
alors alors
sur mon Smart en plantant le piolet dès
que ça va avec un petit peu compliqué
bah tu tir à fond pour la corde
essaie de marcher dans les marches on
passe pour
regarder un petit peu en haut au cas où
il y a un bloc de neige
logiquement c'est que de la neige
à la suite de la section j'attaque une
pente de 50 mètres
42 degrés de dénivelé un vrai mur
qu'est-ce que c'est dur
la pente elle est raide en fait après
plusieurs passages c'est un peu plus
difficile on a bien fait de faire passer
Benjamin en dernier
je me dis que
alors la montagne ça vous gagne
j'ai quand même fait
jamais grimper moi il y avait rien
je m'enfonçais
déjà là je suis à la limite de ce que je
peux faire
est-ce que au moins c'est en fait chier
jusque là il est du relais
[Musique]
la haute montagne sans sac et sans
armement c'est déjà très dur alors
imaginez l'effort de ces soldats
lorsqu'ils cumulent toutes les
difficultés plus une
un noir total la nuit absolue
il est 4h30 du matin la colonne se
présente au pied d'une falaise
pratiquement à la verticale sans aucune
lumière pour rester invisible on ne voit
pas à 2 mètres ils ont leur 25 îlots sur
le dos plus les skis les raquettes et le
FAMAS
[Musique]
c'est bien couvert en plus on est dans
un petit boulet on est dans la forêt et
le but c'est vraiment de
de créer des automatismes la nuit comme
ça et de garder en fait c'est savoir
faire parce que les équipements en
général équipé du haut c'est bien mais
notre but c'est la progression de nuit
et pour passer des feuilles comme ça
dans la falaise faut qu'il s'entraînent
et qui s'entraînent en avant
10 minutes de monter il fait moins 5
mais l'effort intense les préserve du
froid
et les choses sérieuses ne font que
commencer
à la radio
ils finissent l'ascension au lever du
jour alors qui est le plateau des
Glières au lieu de la résistance
française
ici en 1944 500 maquisards affrontés à
l'armée allemande c'était le point de
départ de la libération de la
Haute-Savoie
allez en avant sans une minute de pause
l'exercice continue
maintenant c'est la guerre
derrière cette crête l'ennemi a délogé
je suis avec le groupe d'assaut les
hommes progressent à l'affût sur les
hauteurs le groupe d'appui montez les
premiers ils sont en place depuis plus
d'une heure l'ennemi dans leur viseur
l'ennemi il est là
l'exercice se fait avec des balles
[Musique]
militaire c'est une personne ici cette
personne c'est l'ennemi
et il semble résister
j'avais l'impression qu'il maîtrisait
mais en fait pas vraiment
[Musique]
l'attaque est ratée les formateurs sont
furieux
[Musique]
Face à Nous je repère Jérôme visiblement
très énervé poste par poste les chefs de
groupe en prennent pour leur grade
[Musique]
d'abord c'est golf 2 le groupe d'appui
sur les hauteurs
[Applaudissements]
des
équipes
est-ce que chacun fait
donc là on fait un arrêt sur place pour
que chacun reprenne bien la mesure de la
situation que le groupe qui a fuit et
qui renseigne sur mesure vraiment de
donner quelque chose d'efficace puisque
le but c'est quand même de s'emparer du
col avec le moins impair possible
donc jusque là ça va
je suis pas très content mais ça va
reprise de l'exercice le recadrage a
porté ses fruits la section revient au
fondamentaux du combat en montagne
s'appuyer mutuellement et déborder
l'ennemi
[Musique]
que l'objectif était de s'emparer du col
pour le lever du soleil opération
réussie à quelques minutes près
c'est très difficile une prise de colle
donc
même en tant que combattant on l'a tous
un peu peur de d'arriver à ça après
après on est entraîné pour ça mais pour
ça donc
[Musique]
comme ça qu'on arrive à faire le pas sur
la peur et
après il y a pas vraiment l'entraînement
pour ça quoi
on peut pas s'entraîner à ne pas voir
peur c'est sûr mais on peut toujours
s'entraîner à devenir plus fort et plus
encore plus fort que ce qu'on est
une seconde
on va sûrement se faire engueuler je
pense
[Applaudissements]
les chefs de groupe je ne vous ai pas
entendu commander
il y a pas de puéril donc vous commandez
à quoi
à la voix donc quand ça tire
faut que ça parle quoi faut qu'on entend
ce que vous dites d'accord le GV qui a
50 mètres si ça tire de partout il faut
qu'il l'entende donc les chefs de groupe
par l'effort
d'accord
objectif effectivement là les gens qui
ont été un Afghanistan si les gens vous
tirent dessus à 100 m vous êtes tous
comme des fruits ou des couverts
on est derrière un caillot voilà donc là
il y a pas de caillou il y a des sapins
il y a des il y a de la neige il y a des
petites dépressions
appuyez-vous mutuellement d'accord
la saut en ligne 1914
c'est peut-être efficace mais c'est pas
ce qu'on attend de vous ici d'accord
c'est de vous appuyer les uns les autres
et surtout surtout on n'a pas 800000
mecs à mettre au temps actuellement
d'accord
tactiquement bah il y a encore du boulot
forcément vous le savez d'accord il y a
encore du boulot
il est à peine 8 heures du matin
l'exercice a été riche d'enseignement
c'est la fin de mon initiation au combat
en montagne demain je vais apprendre la
survie en haute montagne mais avant
retour à l'école pour ma dernière nuit
dans un nichon
j'ai deux trois trucs à raconter à
Carole
je te sais sur les sommets des montagnes
non mais je me tais encore une fois
j'étais dans le folklo un peu de du
chasseur alpapant moi c'était en gros
des des beaux gosses bronzés qui quoi en
fait pas du tout c'est pas du tout ça
déjà le chasseur alpha fait du ski